[Music]
[Applause]
pull question for hour two before we
bring in Jason Garrett cedan let me just
hit hour one real quickly uh who had the
best week so far right now it's tied
between the 76ers and the 49ers at about
30% followed closely at 24% by the
Raiders yeah I don't know if they had a
great week and I don't know how good
this job is let me start there with
Jason Garrett former Cowboys head coach
he's on football night in America also
an analyst for Notre Dame
football uh good morning Jason how
attractive is that Raiders job to you
with that roster they have right
now well Dan there's only 32 of these
jobs so they're attractive and um you
know they're certainly going through a
little bit of a a challenging time and
and anytime you you have a regime and
then you have a new regime and there's
there's trans position within that um
it's more challenging be because they're
turning it over and they made some of
these decisions and now they haven't had
a chance to finish and now a new guy
comes in and he wants to have a plan so
I think that's part of it um but but I I
I do think it's a good starting point to
have a guy like Devonte Adams you have a
playmaker on the offensive side of the
ball you got Josh Jacobs you got you got
some weapons over there that you
certainly can build around um you know
and and you know I worked for Nick sain
for a couple years and he used to always
talk about relative to what and so as a
quarterback you say hey we got Jimmy
Garoppolo and some people say hey he's
not Josh Allen he's not Joe burrow but
relative to what there are a lot of
teams that would like to have Jimmy
Garoppolo as their quarterback and uh so
you know I think there are some pieces
in place there on the offensive side of
the ball and uh I think the guy who gets
a chance to go in there hopefully he
gets a chance to have some impact on on
building the team the way he wants to
build it but there's some Cornerstone
pieces there that you like yeah and Max
Crosby is also there he almost fits that
image of the old Raiders uh but I just I
wonder Jimmy Garoppolo is not there for
the Long Haul Devonte Adams contract is
crazy after this year Josh Jacobs you
have him for a little while and they
have the seventh pick in the draft like
is that something that would entice
somebody who already has a good job
let's say in college that they would
want
to one of my favorite players in
football and uh you know I think Dan
Campbell uh is is a good example up in
Detroit uh of a guy who had an
opportunity to go in there and they're
building the team the way he wants to
build it and so I think any job in the
NFL if you have the opportunity to do
that and you have a little time to do
that uh is attractive and uh and you
build it in in the image that you want
and Max Crosby being a Cornerstone piece
uh I I think would fit that bill for the
Raiders so um you know you dive in and
you go the obvious challenge is you're
in the same division as the Chiefs and
all of that but hell there they're 32 of
them and uh you know it's a heck of an
opportunity for somebody how involved is
the coach at the trade
deadline I think it depends on the
building how involved were
you certainly involved in the
discussions um you know I I thought the
communication that we had when we were
at our best in Dallas was really good
you know leading up to the draft leading
up to free agency and then certainly
throughout the trade deadline uh you
know we traded for Amari Cooper one year
and that wasn't right up against against
the trade deadline but it was um you
know we needed a player at that position
and we had we had extensive discussions
about who that player was and eventually
he became available and he made a huge
difference on our team have you ever
said I don't I don't want to trade for
that
guy certainly yes and you have healthy
discussions I don't want to sign that
guy I don't want to trade for that guy I
don't want to draft that guy but uh you
know it's a collabor effort uh the
Personnel people in the really good
organizations are really good at what
they do so it's it's the job of the head
coach to constantly provide the vision
for the football team and then if you
have good communication you say does
this decision fit that vision and and
and the teams that are aligned that way
on a consistent basis and acquiring
players are the ones that play at the
end of the year talking to Jason Garrett
football night in America Studio analyst
also an analyst for Notre Dame
football help me understand what Dabo
Sweeney was railing against a caller on
his radio show like
um did is he I thought it was maybe a
bigger picture where it's like the
manager who tells the Umpire throw me
out because I want my team to get fired
up you got Notre Dame coming to town and
it almost felt like you know sto you
know pressing me to be what I once was
or whatever um but he also want fire up
his team against Notre Dame they're
underdogs at home against Notre Dame
yeah I think that's probably a pretty
good take on it um you know he he he's
been so good if you look at what that
program has done I mean he's been so
good for such a long time uh and not
only winning games and going to the
championship game and all of that but
you know developing developing players
uh you know I love Dabo I'm a huge fan
we had a chance to do the Notre Dame
Clemson game last year and uh just just
getting a more intimate glimpse of that
program I'm so I'm so impressed and you
know there's obvious frustration there
when you have so much success for a long
time and then they're not what they were
this year I'm sure he's feeling some of
that but you know I think people need to
step back and see what he's done and and
and not only the wins but the impact
he's had and you know there's a good
story about Dabo you know when you're a
head coach in the NFL leading up to the
draft you call all your guys in college
football and say hey tell me about your
guys and and for years conversations
with Nick saan or other guys they've had
so many
players and so you try to figure
out the evaluation I worked for Nick for
two years I understood how he talked
about players and um he loves certain
guys it's it's one line just take the
guy you know if if he has TR if he has
trouble with guys he kind of Beats
around the bush a little bit and says
hey if you have a good structure in
place if you have a really good
structure in place this guy can be
successful for you who was the guy that
he just said just take
him oh there so many guys that Nick you
know Jonathan Allen I remember Jonathan
Allen just take the guy he's gonna play
for you know and he's right I mean it
was just such an easy evaluation but you
know when you talk to davo you have to
decipher the guys because every guy is
great every guy is incredible every guy
you know and then you could figure out
the system to say okay this guy's really
better than this guy and you work your
way through it but but I I bring that up
to say that he's had such a positive
impact on so many people on football he
has such great enthusiasm so to see him
frustrated like this I get it I I hope
he gets his old Spirit back because it's
it's a really good thing for all of us
if you ran the Jets do you want Aaron
Rogers back this
season to me it's a health it's just
simply a health issue let's say he's
healthy he's cleared let's say there's
two or three games left got a chance for
the
playoffs absolutely okay this guy's one
of the greatest ones that ever walked
you know and and to give him a chance to
to play is he the same player that he
was 10 years ago I don't know about that
but he's one of the best players in
football and if you could get him back
and and he is truly healthy you're
risking next season what's that you're
risking next season aren't you yeah yeah
I mean and to me that's the question you
know some guys get the competitive
Spirit going and said I'm gonna I'm
gonna beat the timeline I got an ACL but
I'm gonna come back in eight months I'm
going to come back and and and I have a
healthy respect for injuries and making
sure that um you give guys plenty of
time and that comes from experience of
maybe allowing a guy to come back
earlier than he should have and because
we're all competitive we all want the
guy out there and he's showing you in
practice so so I would be a little
concerned about Russian this because
just the nature of that injury but the
if the question is is he completely
healthy yeah absolutely you want him to
play yeah but I'm trying to understand
DeShaun Watson when he's medically
cleared and then they say that he didn't
want to play like how does that happen
that you're medically cleared but then
he doesn't
play well every injury situation is
unique in and of itself and as a head
coach it it's one of the hardest things
you have to
manage and and you know I think without
speaking specifically about him because
I'm not in the conversations when you
have a little issue like that you really
got to get to the bottom of it and and
figure out the why of that and and it
takes constant conversation and you know
some
guys have a little bit of a track
mentality in that they need everything
to be perfect some some guys are mutters
hey I'm fine they tape it up spit on it
let's get going we can I can go play and
so again I'm not speaking specifically
to Deshawn but that's that's that's a
spectrum that you get on and you say
Okay C can he play without everything
being perfect you know and and so you
got to work through those and they're
challenging they really are ultimately
it's a collaborative effort it's players
input along with doctors and trainers
and and as a head coach you just try to
manage as best you can all right you
need to make a choice here on your
quarterback Sunday night Bengals bills
you're the head coach you're starting
with Josh Allen or Joe
burrow you always ask me these questions
yes I do bicher Brady all
this who who you taking Josh Allen Joe
bur Joe bur Joe burrow goes to San
Francisco and doesn't throw an
incomplete pass he's phenomenal and
you're asking me this question um
I love them both obviously who doesn't
they're both great and they're going to
be great players for the next 10 years
they have chances to be Hall of Famers
all of that um I love Josh Allen I don't
like him I love him I love him uh I love
his competitive Spirit you know someone
once told me that it took 13 people to
get secretari in the gates before he won
by 33 lents you know Josh Allen reminds
me of that he reminds me of this
incredible player that you just have to
constantly make sure we get him in the
gates and let him go um so when they do
that he running late he's running less
but is he running
smarter yeah and to me it's it's the
secretary analogy is not necessarily his
running it's just his you know I'm going
to go make the play I'm going to put the
City of Buffalo on my shoulders and I'm
going to go do it and and and experience
tells me that over a 17 Game season in
the NFL that doesn't work so when
they're at their best it's collaborative
everybody's there's a piece of it he's
certainly the focal point and so if he
does that on a consistent basis and
continues to learn how to do that and
they build the team that way I love him
to death I I his competitive spirit is
rare for me but the other guys off the
charts I mean Joe Cool is something else
I think you answered it I did I by by a
nose I'd take Josh Allen okay back again
to Secretariat where you didn't you
didn't have to worry about winning by a
nose hey great to talk to you have fun
on Sunday Bill's Bengals on NBC and
peacock that'll start at 7 Eastern
football night in America thank you jce
thanks Dan always enjoy it all right uh
you got to put him on the hot seat every
time he comes on right you just you
don't let him know what Hot Seat what
seed is going to be warm there